and a unlv student being honored on what
would have been his 21st birthday the
circumstances surrounding his tragic
death and his family's message
plus new covid concerns what health
officials are saying about the latest
virus
variant now this is 8 news now weekend
edition live local now tonight friends
and family continue to mourn for unlv
student who died after participating in
a charity boxing match good evening and
thank you so much for joining us tonight
at six o'clock i'm sasha loftis we want
to get right out to victoria saha she
joins us live now from unlv alumni
amphitheater where that vigil is set for
later tonight victoria
yeah sasha we're still about an hour
away from that start time of that vigil
those who knew nathan valencia and the
unlv community is supposed to be here to
remember a life lost too soon
the ri team first broke the story on
thursday learning valencia collapsed
after a boxing match on november 19th
his family tells us he suffered brain
injuries he passed away four days later
friends say valencia did not have any
experience boxing but wanted to take
part in the charity event as a member of
his fraternity sigma alpha epsilon but
the event was held by the kappa sigma
fraternity those who were present in the
crowd say they weren't there weren't any
medical professionals on site the
lawyers for the valencia family say that
metro police is investigating and a
gofundme in his honor has raised more
than 46 thousand dollars today would
have been valencia's 21st birthday
victoria saha live local now